Yippee-ki-yay movie lovers, it's Jan here.
Although we've seen all the trailers for Infinity
War, Marvel still haven't revealed who Game
of Thrones star Peter Dinklage will be playing
in the film.
So, today, I'm going to give you a breakdown
of who his mystery character is most likely
to be.
And I'm kicking off a brand new Avengers giveaway.
To enter you just need to be a subscriber
and leave me a comment here about the movie.
Also remember to ring the bell to make sure
you get all my new videos!
MCU speculation and mild spoilers ahead for
Thor in Infinity War.
The character Peter Dinklage could well be
playing in the movie is Eitri, King of the
Dwarves of Nidavellir, which is one of the
Nine Realms.
Eitri, who's a master blacksmith, was first
introduced in the Thor comics in the early
1980s and later appeared on the animated TV
series, The Avengers: Earth's Mightiest Heroes.
In the Infinity War movie, Thor travels to
Nidavellir in search of a new weapon.
And in the comics, there is a bond between
Nidavellir and Asgard; indeed, it's the dwarves
who create Thor's hammer Mjolnir as well as
an axe-like hammer called Stormbreaker, which
will be Thor's new weapon in the movie.
In terms of the MCU, the dwarves of Nidavellir
have already made a brief appearance in the
prelude comic to Thor: The Dark World, where
they feared an attack by trolls on their forges
because Asgard couldn't protect them after
the destruction of the Bifrost.
But the dwarves may well play a bigger part
in the Infinity War movie, as there are rumours
that they also created the Infinity Gauntlet
and that there have been casting calls for
actors of short stature.
Another possibility is that Dinklage will
play Pip the Troll, a prince who was transformed
into a troll and who loved to drink and have
a good time.
The character was created by artist-writer
Jim Starlin who also gave us Thanos, Drax
the Destroyer, and Gamora.
Pip's appearances in the comics include the
Infinity Gauntlet storyline and he's a member
of the Infinity Watch which was put together
by Adam Warlock to protect the Infinity Gems.
On top of that, he's also had his mind destroyed
by Thanos, but Adam Warlock came to the rescue,
absorbing Pip's soul into the Soul Gem where
he lived in Soulworld until he was restored
into the real world via the body of a recently
deceased human.
Now, Adam Warlock's introduction to the MCU
was teased in a Guardians of the Galaxy 2
post-credits scene, however, according to
James Gunn, Warlock won't appear till Guardians
3.
But that doesn't necessarily rule Pip out
of Infinity War because, in addition to Pip's
comic-book connections with Thanos, Gamora,
and the Infinity Gems, early last year Peter
Dinklage was spotted getting his hair dyed
red, which is just the right colour to play
Pip the Troll!
There's also a chance that Dinklage is lending
his voice to one of Thanos's Black Order.
In an interview with Vulture, Kevin Feige
said 'there are interesting people doing the
voices.'
So far, it looks like Terry Notary and Tom
Vaughan-Lawlor will be playing two of the
Black Order, possibly Cull Obsidian and Ebony
Maw.
Maybe Dinklage will voice Corvus Glaive, who
we already saw in the trailers attacking Vision
for the Mind Stone with his blade.
Dinklage would certainly fall into the category
of 'interesting people' that Feige mentions,
however, you'd think they might prefer to
give such a well-known actor a visual rather
than a vocal role; then again we do have Bradley
Cooper as the voice of Rocket and James Spader
was Ultron.
So, maybe they think a voice role would potentially
cause less confusion for people who remember
Dinklage as Bolivar Trask in X-Men: Days of
Future Past.
After all, Josh Brolin, for example, plays
Thanos in the MCU through motion-capture and
voice work, but in Deadpool 2 he plays another
Marvel Comics character, Cable, on screen.
Now, I'd love to hear your thoughts and theories
on who Peter Dinklage will be playing!
Let me know in the comments and make sure
you're subscribed for the giveaway.
Tap here to check out my spoiler-free reaction
to 20 minutes of Infinity War footage I saw,
and watch my other Marvel theories in my full
playlist here.
You can also tweet me any questions or comments
@Jan_Gilbert or @FlicksCity.
If you enjoyed this, I really appreciate you
hitting that like button and sharing the video.
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!